[Musique]
nous avons on va être joint en plateau
avec par hatis Barret qui est
conseillère sur le bien-être animal pour
la ville de Poissy bonsoir à tous ce
soir
une entrée j'aime bien
avec un chien voilà alors comment il
s'appelle
petit frère à Paco et c'est le fils je
dirais puisque c'est un membre de la
famille le fils de Céline et Karl Olive
d'accord
vous allez parler vous nous parlez de
propreté animal ce soir dans cette dans
l'émission voilà
[Rires]
j'aimerais revenir avec vous sur le prix
vous avez reçu pour la ville de Poissy
vous avez aussi le label Ville amis des
animaux exactement
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
mot qu'est-ce que c'est ce label alors
ce label en fait c'est ça a été mis en
place par par la Région Île-de-France
donc qui a mis en place le label Ville
ami des animaux et en fait elle a voulu
accentuer sur trois axes ces trois axes
sont promouvoir le respect du bien-être
animal valoriser la place de l'animal en
ville et renforcer le lien de l'animal
de compagnie auprès de nos citoyens en
fragilisés voilà il est très possessif
et donc vous avez reçu ce prix de la
part de Valérie Pécresse la Présidente
de la Région
Île-de-France voilà tout à fait donc en
fait toutes les villes peuvent
participer la ville de Poissy a
participé pour la première fois et donc
on a eu le label avec la mention de pas
de place sur trois pour une première
participation donc il y a d'autres
communes des Yvelines qui ont reçu ce ce
prix ville ami des animaux alors
saint-germain-en-lay a reçu les
encouragements du jury mort par réseau
vendredi ont obtenu le label une pâte
Chanteloup-les-Vignes Coignières plaisir
Vélizy-Villacoublay Verneuil-sur-Seine
et carrière sous Poissy ont aussi eu le
label de pâtes et enfin Montesson a
obtenu le label 3 pattes alors on va
revenir un petit peu sur sur l'idée de
cette chronique vous allez nous parler
de propreté des animaux du chien et du
chat alors est-ce qu'il faut laver son
chien ou son chat alors ben écoutez en
fait moi ce que je veux te faire d'abord
vous poser la question autour de la
table une question est-ce que à chaud
comme ça si vous pensez qu'il faut laver
son chien ou son chat en posant juste
de manière naturelle moi j'avais envie
de dire oui ben moi aussi mais j'avoue
que je savais
moi je dirais oui pour les chiens après
pour les chats
[Rires]
en fait il y a pas de bonne réponse ou
de mauvaises réponses tout le monde à
tout le monde a raison il y a pas de
règles
les animaux n'ont pas les mêmes besoins
que les humains ils n'ont pas besoin
d'être lavés tous les jours puisque en
fait leur peau peut être fragilisé par
un lavage très fréquent tout dépend en
fait de l'environnement leur
environnement intérieur extérieur voilà
et alors du coup concernant les chats
est-ce qu'il faut les laver alors
concernant les chats ce sont des animaux
propres on dit même l'expression la
toilette la toilette de chat les chats
ça dépend également de l'environnement à
chacun attention au micro parce que
sinon on va plus vous entendre un chat
qui en surpoids c'est comme les animaux
le surpoids c'est pas bon donc il va
avoir du mal à accéder à certaines
parties de son corps donc on va lui
proposer de lui faire une toilette
concernant bah écoutez un chat qui va
avoir des puces oui on va lui proposer
de faire une toilette le chat qui a des
poils longs ou qui a des dans les poils
oui on va lui proposer de on va l'aider
à faire sa toilette et alors pour les
chiens comment ça se passe alors pour
les chiens le lavage est un peu plus
fréquent concernant en concernant les
chiens on peut le laver donc toutes les
toutes les quatre semaines tout dépend
également de son activité donc quand il
fait très chaud pendant la canicule bien
sûr va falloir laver son chien un chien
qui va rentrer de balade bah il va avoir
de la boue sur lui donc oui on va lui
proposer un bain et puis bah voilà
l'habituer l'habitude vous pouvez
commencer ce que je vous conseille c'est
de laver votre chien après l'âge de
trois mois comme ça il pourra faire ses
défenses immunitaires et ça va lui
éviter de d'avoir un rhume ok
alors comment comment est-ce qu'on fait
pour habituer son chien à prendre un
bain parce que souvent c'est quand même
un moment qu'ils apprécient pas trop
alors c'est une bonne question en fait
il vous est toujours de très bonnes
questions pas de stress pas de stress
pas de précipitation déjà donc on
prépare son chien on lui démêle les
poils avec bien je crois
que tout le monde il est poli un chien
qui est très poli
donc on lui démêle d'abord les poils de
l'eau tiède une bonne ambiance
n'hésitez pas à donner une friandise
donc
surtout on fait attention à son point
pas de pas de shampoing pour pour chat
au niveau du chien pas du shampoing pour
animal pour humain au niveau pour pour
son chien
pas de shampoing dans les yeux pour les
oreilles on fait attention pour éviter
l'outil ça peut ça peut arriver vous
séchez bien au niveau de son ventre au
niveau de ses pattes j'ai à nouveau sa
serviette peut-être qu'il pense qu'il va
prendre un bain
[Rires]
de préserver nos micros surtout jamais
d'eau de Javel pas de produits
hydroalcooliques parce qu'il y a des
informations comme ça qui circulent sur
des réseaux sociaux jamais de produits
s'il vous plaît dangereux c'est pas bon
pour la santé du chien alors Rocky qui
est là qui vous fait plein de bisous il
me semble propre enfin en tout cas il
est très propre et lui ça lui pose pas
de problème le gars alors lui voilà
c'est la particularité c'est pour ça que
j'ai choisi un chien qui est très propre
et il se la fait déjà parce qu'il fait
du jogging il entraîne de son maître
grâce à lui son maître monsieur Carly il
a fait beaucoup de progrès au niveau de
du jogging et puis il reçoit beaucoup de
caresses ça soit beaucoup de caresses il
y a beaucoup de fans
est-ce que vous avez des animaux autour
du plateau non pas du tout
ouais j'ai un beagle à la maison
ou pas
[Rires]
[Musique]
merci beaucoup en tout cas à 10 % c'est
précisions
il faut prendre soin de voilà merci en
tout cas il vous a fait votre toilette à
vous